schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
mindestens
497 betroffene von sexualisierter gewalt
das ist das schreckliche ergebnis eines
gutachtens zu missbrauchsfällen in der
katholischen kirche im erzbistum münchen
und freising das gutachten das wurde
heute in münchen vorgestellt und dabei
werden auch vorwürfe gemacht gegen den
ehemaligen papst benedikt und gegen
kardinal marx wegen fehlerhaften
verhalten und untätigkeit heißt es in
dem gutachten
und marx will sich kardinal marx will
sich in zehn minuten äußern deshalb sind
wir für euch live werden euch da alle
fragen zu beantworten und eben auch
dieses statement live mitverfolgen und
deshalb schalten wir jetzt auch zunächst
mal zu meiner kollegin zu der reporterin
sara schuhen nach münchen sie steht vor
der ehemaligen karmeliterkirche in
münchen wo kardinal marx sich äußern
möchte hallo sarah
hallo er äußert sich jetzt hand guten
abend er äußert sich jetzt kardinal marx
also mehrere stunden später denn dieses
gutachten das wurde also heute vormittag
schon vorgestellt wieso war magst du
nicht gleich heute morgen bei der
vorstellung des gutachtens dabei und hat
sich diesen vorwürfen gestellt
warum er nicht persönlich erschienen ist
darüber kann man nur spekulieren
tatsächlich hat er keine gründe für sein
fernbleiben genannt aber man muss sagen
mit dem heutigen druck ist mit dem
heutigen tag ist ja ganz massiv unter
druck geraten das gutachten wirft ihm
persönlich mindestens zwei fälle vor in
denen es viel verhalten von seiner seite
gab zwei missbrauchsfälle die er hätte
weiter melden müssen wo er nicht tätig
geworden ist das ist sicherlich einer
der schwersten tage heute in seiner
amtszeit als kardinal von der diözese
münchen freising und dass er nicht da
erschienen das persönlich das kam auch
nicht gut an wenn man das so sagen will
also eine der anwältinnen die dieses
1700 seiten starke konvolut heute
vorgestellt hat ja gleich zu beginn der
pressekonferenz gesagt dass hier sehr
bedauert dass kardinal marx ihre
persönlichen einladung nicht gefolgt ist
und gekommen ist denn das wäre
sicherlich auch ein wichtiges zeichen
für alle opfer für alle betroffenen
gewesen und genau um die soll es heute
auch natürlich insbesondere auch in
dieser sendung gehen jenseits losgelöst
von diesen vorwürfen gegen den
ehemaligen papst gegen kardinal marx und
was da heute genau passiert ist und
worum es geht das hat barbara lueg für
uns zusammengefasst
diese pressekonferenz ist voller
sprengkraft denn im fokus stehen
mächtige kirchenmänner joseph ratzinger
emeritierter papst und frühere münchner
erzbischof und seine nachfolger dort die
kardinäle wetter und marx wer hat was
gewusst die gutachter belasten heute die
hauptakteure schwer und es geht an
diesem tag noch weit über sexuellen
missbrauch hinaus wird vertuschung
endlich als das erkannt was sie ist
nämlich verrat an den grundlagen
christlichen glaubens sein fall steht im
zentrum priester peter h werden
besonders viele missbrauchs taten
zugeschrieben zunächst als kaplan in
essen in den 70ern doch statt in
pädophilen priester damals zu entlassen
wird er nach münchen versetzt joseph
ratzinger ist dort zu der zeit
erzbischof auch hier missbrauch peter h
kinder sexuell wird verurteilt und
dennoch erneut versetzt wer also trägt
schuld eine über 80 seitige
stellungnahme hatte joseph ratzinger der
emeritierte papst und ehemaliger
münchner erzbischof den anwälten zur
verfügung gestellt heute nun wird er
schwer belastet in insgesamt vier fällen
sind wir zu der einschätzung gelangt
dass dem damaligen erzbischof kardinal
ratzinger in fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs ein fehlverhalten
vorzuwerfen ist auch kardinal wetter und
dem amtierenden münchner erzbischof marx
werfen die gutachter fehlverhalten vor
marx will sich am nachmittag äußern
wir werden später in dieser sendung auch
gelegenheit haben mit einem betroffenen
zu sprechen
jetzt aber zunächst noch mal nach
münchen zu seiner show sarah wie ist
denn die stimmung wenn man das so sagen
kann im erzbistum jetzt also nach
bekanntgabe dieser wirklich großen fälle
dieser 497 betroffenen und das ja eben
wahrscheinlich nur die tiere ja die zahl
die bekannte ist also wie ist die ist
die stimmung bei den menschen
ja das ist erstmal diese schiere zahl du
hast es gesagt fast 500 opfer und weit
über 100 mutmaßliche täter der ganz
grosse teil davon kleriker priester im
amt und diese priester die waren in
gemeinden hier im bistum eingesetzt und
die gemeinden hatten keine ahnung wer da
kommt mit welcher vorgeschichte die sind
männer kamen und wem sie da tatsächlich
auch ihre kinder anvertraut haben und
dieser ganz besonders krasser fall
dieser peter harder den gutachtern heute
sogar ein eigenes unter gutachten wert
war er war eben schon verurteilter
sexualstraftäter als er in die gemeinde
garching an der alz hier in bayern
gekommen ist und die gemeindemitglieder
hatten auch einfach die wurden nicht
vorgewarnt es wurde in ihnen nie
bestätigt die gerüchte wartens war aber
was mit diesem para los ist und er
konnte dann in diesen 20 jahren in denen
er dieser gemeinde eingesetzt war
nochmal vier jungen mindestens
missbrauchen ich habe mit gläubigen aus
dieser gemeinde gesprochen und haben
gesagt die verletzungen die verheerungen
die dauern eigentlich bis heute an
gibt es auf der einen seite die die bis
heute nicht glauben wollen dass dieser
pfarrer wirklich schuldig geworden ist
und auf der anderen seite die die sich
um eine lückenlose aufklärung bemühen
und sich auch selber mit schuldig fühlen
weil sie all die jahre nicht gesehen
haben was da zwischen ihnen passiert ist
in ihrer mitte das ist eine gemeinde
aber dies vielleicht ganz ein ganz
schönes beispiel ein ganz gutes beispiel
dafür was solche priester dann auch
anrichten und welche folgen das auch
jahre und jahrzehnte noch hat nachdem
solche männer in solchen gemeinden tätig
waren und das haben wir auch viele
berichtet mit denen ich da gesprochen
habt dass da eine ganze generation auch
tatsächlich für die kirche verloren geht
denn die damals ministranten dagewesen
sind unter diesem pfarrer die haben der
kirche fast ausnahmslos den rücken
gekehrt
danke sarah schon nach münchen für den
moment und wir haben in dieser sendung
zeit für eure fragen für die kommentare
die ihr jederzeit gerne per mail
bestellen könnt oder direkt im stream
und ich habe auch einen experten hier im
studio bin also nicht alleine wir können
also diese fragen nämlich stellen an
jürgen erbacher unseren leiter der
redaktion kirche und leben katholisch
schönen guten abend hallo oder guten
nachmittag er so kannst du ganz so spät
ist es noch nicht wir warten jetzt
gemeinsam noch auf das statement von
kardinal marx die erste frage die sich
natürlich auch gerade für betroffene
vielleicht stellt wie was ist das für
ein zeichen dass er jetzt also abwesend
war da heute vormittag und jetzt erst
spricht wie es das einzuordnen also ich
muss gestehen ich bin persönlich auch
sehr überrascht gewesen als ich anfang
der woche hörte dass das gar nicht
geplant ist dass der kardinal kommen
soll wir haben dann immer wieder auch
noch mal nachgefragt beim erzbistum ich
glaube es wäre ein ganz wichtiges
zeichen gewesen sich diesen dingen
auszusetzen den ergebnissen des
gutachtens der der arbeit auch die die
anwälte jetzt in den letzten jahren zwar
2020 gemacht haben zum einen sich
auszusetzen zum anderen aber auch ein
klares zeichen an die betroffenen ich
bin hier präsent ich stelle mich dem ich
denke es hätte jeder verstanden wenn er
dann nicht gleich ein statement
abgegeben hätte aber da zu sein das wäre
wichtig gewesen warum er nicht da war
aus dem erzbistum gibt es da keine keine
besonderen gründe dafür mann sagte wir
waren durch zwei hochrangige personen
vertreten den generalvikar und die
verwaltungschefin des erzbistums das
erzbistum war auftraggeber von daher war
es für uns okay und wir haben in einer
woche eine pressekonferenz in der den
kardinal marx genau vorstellen wird
welche konsequenzen wir aus diesem
gutachten ziehen also bin mir nicht
sicher ob man das auch richtig
eingeschätzt hat beim erzbistum was das
für eine wirkung entfalten wird wir
haben schon die ersten fragen bei uns im
stream und da geht es auch mal ganz
grundsätzlich erst noch mal darum da
möchte j l bei youtube gerne wissen wer
hat das gutachten überhaupt durchgeführt
und in die person schreibt nach
hoffentlich nicht die kirche selbst also
die kirche das erzbistum münchen und
freising ist auftraggeber durchgeführt
wurde es durch die anwaltskanzlei also
in dem sinne möglichst weitestgehend
unabhängig natürlich kann die
anwaltskanzlei nur mit den akten
arbeiten die ihnen das erzbistum zur
verfügung stellt aber da war heute von
den anwälten nicht zu hören dass es da
probleme gab und im unterschied zu
anderen gutachten den anderen bistümern
welt worden sind schon haben hier die
anwälte auch nochmal zeit zeugen befragt
also sie haben quasi auch noch mal
selber wirklich recherchiert und mit
menschen gesprochen um unter umständen
auch ein abgleich machen zu können was
findet sich in den akten und wir haben
menschen wir haben auch betroffene das
seinerzeit wahrgenommen wir haben noch
ungefähr eine minute
wenn es pünktlich los geht das also kann
ihn ein mag sich äußert aber dann also
gerne noch eine frage aus dem stream die
hier aufgreifen möchte cornell bei
facebook fragt sich welche konsequenzen
könnte die affäre und jetzt geht es aber
los wir schalten also erstmal nach
münchen und danach geht's weiter mit
euren fragen
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zudem presse
statement von kardinal marx ich habe vor
beginn noch zwei technische hinweise
das eine ist wir haben ja für nächste
woche zu einer pressekonferenz
eingeladen bei der die erzdiözese alle
ihre fragen zum gutachten beantworten
wird wir bitten um verständnis dass das
heute nicht möglich ist weil wir das
zunächst auch mal lesen und gründlich
prüfen müssen aber nächsten donnerstag
sie wurden auch schon eingeladen 11 uhr
katholische akademie die adresse ist
bekannt sind sie herzlich eingeladen
noch etwas zweite wurde herr kardinal
beginnt wir hatten heute die kanzlei
westphal kasse gebeten auch unsere neue
anlauf und beratungsstelle zu erwähnen
dass haben sie zwar getan aber nicht
ganz richtig
es gibt deswegen hier nochmal der
vollständigkeit halber es gibt eine neue
anlaufstelle die mit dem heutigen tag
jeweils von montag bis samstag von 9 bis
20 uhr während der nächsten wochen für
betroffene sexuellen missbrauchs
erreichbar ist und diese neue anlauf und
beratungsstelle hat die telefonnummern
jetzt kommt die richtige
089 in münchen 21 37 77 000 ich sage es
nochmal münchen 21 37 770 0 vielen dank
jetzt hat der herr kardinal das wort
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
mein erster gedanke gilt heute den
betroffenen
sexuellen missbrauchs durch kirchliche
vertreter
priester und andere mitarbeiter im raum
der kirche unheil und leid erfahren
haben in einem erschreckenden ausmaß
ich bin erschüttert und beschämt
für mich haben die begegnungen mit
betroffenen sexuellen missbrauchs eine
wende bewirkt
sie haben eine wahrnehmung der kirche
verändert und verändern diese auch
weiterhin
wie ich immer wieder gesagt habe fühle
ich mich als erzbischof von münchen und
freising
mitverantwortlich für die institution
kirche in den letzten jahrzehnten
als der amtierende erzbischof bitte ich
deshalb im namen der erzdiözese
um entschuldigung für das leid das
menschen im raum der kirche in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten
zugefügt wurde
dass sexueller missbrauch in der kirche
nicht ernst genommen wurde dass die
täter oft nicht in rechter weise zur
rechenschaft gezogen wurden dass es
einen weg sehen von verantwortlichen
gegeben hat wissen wir seit jahren
genau deshalb haben wir seit dem ersten
gutachten
dass wir 2010 beauftragt haben das heute
vorgestellte gutachten bei der kanzlei
ws wie in auftrag gegeben
es ist ein wichtiger
und unverzichtbarer baustein für die
aufarbeitung von fällen sexuellen
missbrauchs in unserem erzbistum und
auch für die kirche insgesamt
seit 2010 wurde im ersten bis zum schon
vieles geändert und umgesetzt
und damit sind wir längst nicht am ende
wir
werden auch anhand der empfehlungen des
aktuellen gutachtens weitere
veränderungen beraten und umsetzen
gerade weil es ein so umfangreiches
gutachten ist beschäftigen wir uns
intensiv damit werden es genießen
analysieren und über ergebnisse und
weitere konsequenzen nachdenken und
beraten
der generalvikar klinkern frau dr
hermann und ich werden zeitnah mit den
betroffenen bei rat und der kommission
zu unabhängigen aufarbeitung in den
austausch treten
ich hoffe sehr dass wir am nächsten
donnerstag erste perspektiven aufzeigen
und den weiteren weg skizzieren können
dabei werden die bistums
verantwortlichen weiterhin eng
zusammenarbeiten
wir haben heute
das gutachten erhalten
selbstverständlich habe ich die
pressekonferenz verfolgt der
generalvikar frau amtschefin und ich
werden jetzt das gutachten
gemeinsam analysieren wir handeln
gemeinsam
jetzt ist die zeit die impulse die das
gutachten gibt aufzugreifen und weitere
schritte in die zukunft zu gehen
die missbrauchskrise ist und bleibt eine
tiefe erschütterung für die kirche und
zur aufarbeitung und zum weiteren weg
gehört die orientierung an den opfern
des missbrauchs die aufarbeitung von
falschen machtstrukturen und haltungen
aber es geht um mehr
es geht um die erneuerung der kirche es
geht um das was wir auch im synodalen
weg in deutschland versuchen und
vorantreiben
denn die synodale weg ist ja ausgegangen
von der mhg studie und ihren analysen
aufarbeitung des sexuellen missbrauchs
kann nicht getrennt werden vom weg der
veränderung der erneuerung und der
reform der kirche
daran werden wir gemeinsam
weiterarbeiten
zum schluss betone ich noch einmal dass
die perspektive der betroffenen für uns
im erzbistum münchen und freising
jetzt im mittelpunkt steht auch um
schritte in die zukunft zu gehen
ich danke ihnen und bitte um verständnis
dass für fragen in der nächsten woche
dann die gelegenheit gegeben wird
vielen dank
statement von kardinal marx ein recht
kurzes statement für fragen hat er sich
jetzt nicht zur verfügung gestellt das
soll also nächste woche passieren jürgen
erbacher von also unser kirchenexperte
wie ist das jetzt einzuschätzen dieses
knappe und wirklich sehr kurzes
statement von gerade mal fünf minuten
was wir gehört haben gut ist war im
vorfeld schon aus dem erzbistum köln aus
dem erzbistum münchen zu hören dass es
ein sehr kurzes statement sein wird der
kardinal wolle klare worte sprechen wir
haben hier denke ich einmal drei
wichtige punkte das eine ist dass er
sagt die betroffenen stehen im
mittelpunkt das ist der erste gedanke
von ihm und auch des erzbistums da kann
man vielleicht später noch einmal
vertiefen ein bisschen gucken weil das
gutachten mit blick auf seine person da
ein bisschen kritischer ist und etwas
anderes sagt der zweite punkt die bitte
um entschuldigung noch einmal klar
ausgesprochen
das ist glaube ich an so einem tag
durchaus auch ein richtiger ort das dann
zu machen und sehr wichtig für ihn es
geht nicht ohne veränderungen
aufarbeitung ohne veränderung und reform
der kirche das ist für ihn nicht möglich
da gibt es auch andere stimmen ich
glaube die mehrheit der deutschen
bischöfe teilt dieses anliegen aber es
gibt auch eine minderheit in der
deutschen bischofskonferenz die würden
die gerade diesen letzten aspekt nicht
unterschreiben und auch aus rom kommen
da durchaus kommt da durchaus auch
gegenwind aber das sind glaube ich noch
mal so drei punkte die ihm wichtig waren
an diesem tag zu markieren und ich
glaube von seiner seite oder das von
seiten des erzbistums ist ein bisschen
auch die choreographie heute sprechen
die gutachter und und das erzbistum die
kirche die reagiert sag ich mal an einem
an einem nächsten tag um heute die
ergebnisse mal wirken zu lassen und
sprechen zu lassen was interessant war
wovon jetzt natürlich auch keine rede
war was aber heute ja auch größere
wellen geschlagen hat war durchaus schon
auch inwieweit der ehemalige papst
benedikt da irgendwie natürlich belastet
wird in dem gutachten wir haben aber
auch einen o ton von der konferenz von
der pressekonferenz des gutachtens heute
früh in dem wir erst noch mal reinhören
bevor wir darüber sprechen
wenn er uns vorliegt
kann ich gerne auch wiedergeben was da
gesagt wurde aber gerade der beitrag ist
also hören da mal kurz rein ich
formuliere zurückhaltend wir erhalten
die aussage oder die angabe des papstes
benedikt er sei in dieser sitzung nicht
anwesend gewesen
als wenig glaubwürdig
als wenig glaubwürdig wurde da ja dass
die stellungnahme des ehemaligen papst
bezeichnet wie ist das einzuordnen dass
da jetzt also die das gutachten sagt das
ist ja wenig glaubwürdig da steht der
aussage gegen aussage jetzt wenn der
papst quasi was anderes angegeben hat
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger schritt
hin zur aufarbeitung dieses konkreten
fall ist es geht ja um einen fall eines
priesters der aus dem bistum essen 1980
nach münchen kam und dann dort auch
wieder in der seelsorge eingesetzt wurde
und die frage ist jetzt wusste der
damalige erzbischof joseph ratzinger
über die geschichte dieses mannes
bescheid oder nicht und in der tat steht
im moment aussage gegen aussage
das ist eine sache die wird jetzt gerade
schon in den letzten wochen auch wurde
das diskutiert heute kommen wir im
schritt weiter indem jetzt in dem
gutachten sehr viele detailinformationen
gegeben werden und wir haben ja gerade
in dem ton gehört die gutachter gehen
einen schritt weiter und sagen na das
was papst benedikt hier der emeritierte
papst hier schreibt das erscheint
unglaubwürdig jetzt ist wieder benedikt
am zug zu sagen ok bzw auch andere die
sich die quellen jetzt nochmal genau
anschauen okay jetzt müssen wir das
nochmal genau bewerten und ich denke
schon dass hier auch nochmal ein
weiteres statement aus rom aus dem hause
ratzinger benedikt des 16 dann kommen
muss um diese dinge jetzt zu erklären
denn aktuell man sieht ja auch die
ersten schlagzeilen schon
benedikt der sechzehnte und das ist für
einen emeritierten papst natürlich eine
schlagzeile die so nicht stehen bleiben
kann und wo jetzt die frage ist wer
schafft hier aufklärung da sehe ich
natürlich auch gleich viele fragen bei
uns hier auch bei facebook cornell fragt
sich welche konsequenzen könnte diese
affäre nennt erst für kardinal marx und
auch für den ehemaligen papst benedikt
damals ratzinger haben also wenn wir bei
benedikt dem sechzehnten bleiben denke
ich sind es zwei dinge das eine ist die
frage natürlich
heute klingt das in einigen äußerungen
auch schon an wie wird sein lebenswerk
bewertet wenn jetzt diese dinge im raum
stehen und diese dinge nicht geklärt
werden das ist das eine konkrete
konsequenzen benedikt der sechzehnte ist
emeritierter papst also er kann von
keinem amt zurücktreten ich denke was
hier erwartet wird gerade auch von den
betroffenen ist noch einmal dass er sich
doch noch mal in sich geht und sich die
frage stellt ob er sich hier nicht einer
verantwortung zu stellen hat und das
auch noch mal klar ausspricht also das
sind jetzt die punkte mit blick auf
papst benedikt den emeritierten papst
was kardinal marx an betrifft muss man
sehen was er für konsequenzen aus dem
aus dem gutachten jetzt zieht er hatte
ja letztes jahr im sommer schon einmal
papst franziskus seinen rücktritt
angeboten weil er zum einen
verantwortung für persönliche fehler
übernehmen wollte im kontext der
aufarbeitung und des umgangs mit
sexualisierter gewalt aber er wollte
auch verantwortung für das system kirche
übernehmen franziskus hat damals gesagt
mach weiter
marx hat nicht ausgeschlossen noch mal
einen rückstand einen rücktritt
anzubieten ob jetzt schon der zeitpunkt
gekommen ist oder ob vielleicht auch
noch andere dinge dazu kommen müssen die
frage auch wie hat er in seinem früheren
bistum trier agiert mit
missbrauchsfällen das steht auch noch
eine untersuchung aus also ich denke für
kardinal marx könnt ihr natürlich noch
einmal ein rücktrittsangebot im raum
stehen aktuell halte ich es für
unwahrscheinlich ich denke er wird er
schauen wie können wir im system dinge
verändern und wird so klang es jetzt am
ende das war fast schon eine kampfansage
an die kritiker davon reform wird sich
jetzt noch mal intensiver dafür
einsetzen dass die systemischen ursachen
angegangen werden danke für die
einschätzung für den moment sie bleiben
bei uns jürgen erbacher aber wir wollen
jetzt auch noch mal ganz konkret darauf
schauen was das ja auch bedeutet für die
wir haben es gehört fast 500 betroffenen
und wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit auch
gleich mit einem betroffenen zu sprechen
mit wilfried fesselmann entschuldigung
wilfried fesselmann aus gelsenkirchen er
wurde als kind von einem kaplan
missbraucht und der wurde auch in diesem
gutachten sehr prominent betrachtet
dieser fall wir schauen ganz kurz in
einem beitrag der uns herr fesselmann
kurz vorstellt
er ist einer der betroffenen wilfried
fesselmann messen in sankt andreas
passierte es der damalige kaplan haar
lud ihn ein in sein haus in den
sommerferien
1979 zunächst schaute man fernsehen dann
berührte ihn der kirchenmitarbeiter zog
sich zunächst selbst aus später kam es
zum oralsex mit dem minderjährigen
kaplan h wurde nicht angezeigt nicht
bestraft nur woanders eingesetzt später
im erzbistum münchen freising und der
erzbischof ratzinger nur sein fall nimmt
heute unter die seiten im heute
vorgestellten gutachten einen
hunderte seiten nimmt dieser fall ein
herr fesselmann wilfried fesselmann sehr
schön dass ihr heute mit uns sprechen
vielen dank und schönen guten nachmittag
hätte man wie wichtig war dieser tag
heute für sie dieses gutachten was was
bedeutet das für sie heute
ja ist ja wichtig dass endlich mal die
wahrheit ans licht kommt 2010 wurde der
fall ja auch schon öffentlich
und es hat sich in den letzten zwölf
jahren so gut wie gar nichts getan
sie haben es angesprochen genau es gab
ein so ein erstes gutachten schon was
eben nicht öffentlich gemacht wurde 2010
zwölf jahre sind seitdem vergangen
viele jahre für sie die wagen quasi für
sie wie haben sie das statement von
kardinal marx also heute nur diese fünf
minuten wahrgenommen
ja ich habe mir schon gedacht dass er da
nur ganz kurz darauf eingeht weil
es war ja damals so
ich bin ja dieses opfer wo in diesem
gutachten gesagt worden ist wegen dieser
erpressung ich war 2008 2006 und 2008
hatte ich zum ersten mal da e-mails nach
münchen geschickt um hals kaplan oder
fahrrad zu stoppen und
das wurde ja dann auch offengelegt und
der herr marx bzw das bistum münchen hat
mir dann die staatsanwaltschaft
traunstein nach hause geschickt um mich
halten mundtot zu machen
sie waren also sie wurden quasi opfer
waren betroffen also bevor dieser
besagte kaplan überhaupt erst nach
münchen kam sie haben also da schon im
vorfeld auf aufgemerkt das muss man hier
ganz klar sagen wie schwer ist das
vielleicht auch sie waren elf jahre alt
als kind überhaupt irgendwann darüber
sprechen zu können wie war das bei ihnen
ja nach der tat hat es natürlich meine
mutter hatte mir nicht geglaubt und war
ja das war 79 und da war die zeit ja
total anders na ja da gab es dieses wort
missbrauch gab es ja eigentlich nicht da
hat man nie darüber geredet dass wurde
selbst in der eigenen familie halt
verschwiegen naja und dann hat es war es
bei mir so die auslösern dass ich dann
mir schwindelig wurde ich wusste nicht
warum
panikattacken ich konnte nicht mehr
arbeiten gehen das waren dann diese
spätfolgen die dann auf kam von diesem
missbrauch
das beantwortet glaube ich auch hier
eine frage bei facebook von mathilde
thiel die schreibt schulen familie
jugendämter erkennen signale bei
missbrauch wieso konnten hier niemand
vorbeugend klaffen es gibt da natürlich
auch noch situationen da ist das gar
nicht so einfach sie haben gerade
geschildert wie so etwas aussehen kann
es gibt außerdem auch noch eine frage
bei youtube von andy der sich fragt oder
auch die these aufstellt was nützt denn
den betroffenen das geld wenn der
schmerz tief im kopf sitzt sogleich
wünsche ich mir eine entschädigung sehr
was ist es was sie sich wünschen
irgendwie weitermachen zu können
ja das ist ja was die kirche macht die
hält die opfer klein mit 5000 euro
entschädigung kann man sich ja nichts
nichts aufbauen
der besagte fahrer habe kommt seit 2010
im ruhestand sein geld weiter und die
opfer werden nur mit 5000 euro
abgespeist das kann nicht sein also wenn
die kirche ist nicht leisten kann den
täter zu schützen und weiter zu bezahlen
dann kann der täter dann kann die kirche
es sich auch leisten die opfer natürlich
entsprechend zu entschädigen vielen dank
herr fesselmann dass sie heute mit uns
gesprochen haben und alles gute für sie
herzlichen dank
denn genau diese betroffenen dieser
vielen betroffenen um die es geht die
jetzt so ein bisschen überschattet
werden im prinzip natürlich auch durch
die vorwürfe gegen die beiden
prominenten figuren kardinal marx und
der ehemalige papst aber es geht ja um
diese betroffenen auch die waren heute
thema wurden ganz klar von den
gutachtern zum thema gemacht und auch
hier haben wir noch mal einen ton in den
wir rein hören können von heute
vormittag
das ist mehr als der nicht adäquate
umgang mit den opfern sie wurden nicht
wahrgenommen weder in ihrer körperlichen
noch in ihrer seelische verletzung
geschweige denn im hinblick auf die
dauerhaften tatfolgen
die aufklärungs mängel die wir
konstatieren müssen sind letztlich
ausfluss dieser nicht wahrnehmbar opfer
es ist das desinteresse gegenüber dem
tatgeschehen und dem opfer schicksal und
auch die fehlende bereitschaft durch die
befassung konflikten ausgesetzt zu sein
die es zu bewältigen gilt
wir können jetzt sprechen mit matthias
katsch erst auch für uns in münchen er
ist vom eckigen tisch das ist ein
gemeinnütziger verein der die interessen
von betroffenen sexueller sexualisierter
gewalt im kontext der katholischen
kirche vertritt hallo herr katsch
hallo aus münchen hier geht gerade ein
schnee gewitter über uns hernieder
ich hoffe sie können mich trotzdem gut
verstehen wir können sie wunderbar
verstehen und sie sich hoffentlich ein
bisschen schützen durch ihren schirm der
caps sie haben heute auch zugehört sie
haben ja ich ihnen geschützt aber das
helden sehr gut die hamburger schützen
aber das heldenhafte team nicht das
heldenhafte team jagen dann wie ich
versuche es nicht allzu sehr in die
länge zu ziehen aber es war wichtig dass
wir sprechen eben gerade auch was das
bedeutet für eben die betroffenen diese
ja vertreten wie wichtig ist denn jetzt
schnelle aufarbeitung denn das war
nämlich heute auch täter das war nämlich
heute auch thema dass er die
verantwortlichen ehrlicherweise auch
immer älter werden wirklich sehr sehr
alt sind inzwischen also wie schnell ist
also auch schnelle aufklärung endlich
auch die opfer werden immer älter
wenn ich ganz kurz noch etwas sagen darf
zu dem fall über dem sie gerade
gesprochen haben und mit dem mutigen
betroffenen aus essen der hat ja seine
fortsetzung hier in münchen erfahren
dieser täter der nicht gestoppt wurde
der von papst benedikt in
ins amt hier in münchen geholt wurde und
dann über drei jahrzehnte hinweg weiter
kleine jungen missbraucht hat wie er das
zuvor getan hat
das ist ein wesentlicher teil dieses
sondergerichts in dem umfangreichen
gutachten gewesen weil er so
exemplarisch ist dieses versetzen den
täter schützen an aus dem schussfeld
bringen und woanders wieder zum einsatz
bringen das ist durchgängig in den
fällen zu sehen gewesen hier in münchen
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass man
sich die mühe macht aufzuarbeiten ich
hatte heute vormittag oft das gefühl
dass die leute sagen haben wir doch
alles schon mal gehört das ist doch
jetzt seit zwölf jahren wird darüber
diskutiert auch über den fall benedikt
hatten wir schon mal was berichtet ja
aber durch die akribische arbeit der
anwälte sind beweise auf den tisch
gekommen die zeigen dass benedikt lügt
und da erlaube ich mir ein bisschen
deutlicher zu sprechen als die anwälte
heute vormittag die natürlich sehr
verklausuliert das nur und sehr höflich
ausdrücken er lügt und er liegt um seine
haut zu retten und vor zehn vor zwölf
jahren als der fall schon ein mal in der
presse war da hat das ganze erzbistum
hier angeführt von kardinal marx eine
cover up aktion gefahren den benedikt
aus der schusslinie zu bringen ein
ehemaliger general wieker hat sich
sozusagen in die schusslinie geworfen
hat die kugel auf sich gezogen gesagt es
war mein fehler wir wissen jetzt das
stimmt nicht ratzinger war bei der
entscheidenden sitzung dabei er ist
verantwortlich dafür dass dieser
serientäter in münchen sein unwesen
weiter treiben konnte und die opfer die
hier in münchen in den jahren und
jahrzehnten danach zu beklagen sind die
verdanken sich tatsächlich joseph
ratzinger und ich bin wirklich gespannt
auf die reaktion und auf die art und
weise wie man damit umgehen will das
wird nicht mit einer entschuldigung zu
machen sein ich glaube das erste und
wichtigste an dieser stelle ist wir
brauchen aufklärung und aufarbeitung an
ganz vielen anderen stellen auch in
deutschland auch wo es nicht um einen
papst geht sondern nur um einen bischof
oder ein priester
aufarbeitung hat eine wert für die
betroffenen
sie haben auch immer wieder natürlich
mit den betroffenen kontakt und bekommen
da auch mit wie schwer es natürlich für
manche auch ist dazu sprechen die
anwälte haben es heute auch angesprochen
die dunkelziffer könnte womöglich viel
größer sein was unter ihrer befürchtung
wir brauchen einen geschützten raum
haben die anwälte was heute gemacht und
ich bin ja auch in einer unabhängigen
aufarbeitung kommission tätig seit
einigen jahren und ich weiß wie wichtig
das ist so einen geschützten raum zu
schaffen deswegen plädieren daher dafür
für unabhängige aufarbeitung kommission
dass einem da kein kleriker
gegenübersitzt und kein kirchenmann im
raum ist sondern das wirklich
unabhängige expertinnen und experten dem
man vertrauen kann
meine aussage aufnehmen und dann gehört
natürlich auch
untersuchung von vorgängen dazu bisher
hat man sich vor allem auf fakten
gestützt
jetzt haben wir gesehen was für ein
unterschied das macht wenn zeugen
befragt werden wenn wissel blauer ihr
wissen offenlegen es war ein ganz
dramatischer moment heute als dieses
protokoll was scheinbar verschollen war
auf einmal von dem anwalt präsentiert
wurde das war wie die smoky dann im film
wo ganz klar war ratzinger war bei
dieser entscheidenden sitzung er hat
sogar das wort geführt und hat über
seinen alten widersacher hans küng
vorgetragen in dieser sitzung
das wirklich gibt mir hoffnung dass wir
noch mal in eine neue qualität in der
diskussion über aufarbeitung kommen in
deutschland das hat jetzt viel zu lange
gedauert und das ist verzweifelt für
viele betroffenen die auch keine lust
mehr haben länger zu warten
insofern war das ein erhebender und ein
wichtiger moment heute vielen dank für
diese einschätzung an matthias katsch
vom eckigen tisch vielen dank und
haircut das angesprochen es gibt also
tatsächlich viele betroffene wo es sehr
wichtig ist dass die also auch
anlaufstellen haben und finden bevor ich
jetzt mit jürgen erbacher weiter
sprechen werde und noch einige eurer
fragen beantworten möchte versuche ich
euch mal auf meinem bildschirm zu zeigen
zwei von diesen anlaufstellen die heute
also auch genannt worden sind wir ich
höre gerade aus der regie wir können es
nicht zeigen also es gibt natürlich
anlaufstellen zwei davon möchte ich kurz
nennen die waren heute auch thema es
gibt ganz konkret also eine anlaufstelle
für betroffene von sexualisierter
missbrauch von der erzdiözese münchen
und freising die kann man also im
internet finden da gibt es also auch
eine telefonnummer bei der man anrufen
kann von 9 bis 20 uhr lese ich hier und
grundsätzlich dass es vielleicht auch
sehr wichtig zu denn es gibt ein hilfe
portal sexueller missbrauch auch dort
gibt es eine rufnummer die ist also auch
erreichbar zumindest tagsüber bis 20 uhr
steht hier auch da können also alle
anrufen kinder und jugendliche die also
sexualisierte gewalt erfahren haben dass
nennt sich hilfe portal sexueller
missbrauch das sei nur auch an dieser
stelle gesagt so jetzt können wir mit
jürgen erbacher noch viele von euren
fragen ich habe sehe ich nicht vergessen
sondern hier alle gesehen auch
beantworten und zwar vielleicht kommen
wir erst mal dazu wie es jetzt quasi
weitergeht hier möchte nämlich die 92
bei youtube wissen was passiert nun mit
den tätern so schreibt die person wie
werden diese verfolgt und damit meint
diese personen lese ich hier gerade auch
also alle weiteren die da ja
angesprochen worden sind ihm nicht kann
ihn ein max oder der ehemalige papst
sondern eben jene die da also wirklich
auch täter sind also es gibt zwei dinge
zum einen hat die kanzlei die das
gutachten durchgeführt hat ja schon
angekündigt dass sie bereits vor
längerer zeit
vorgänger an die staatsanwaltschaft in
münchen übergeben hat das heißt da wird
einmal von staatlichen stellen geprüft
was von den dingen die jetzt bei dem
gutachten erarbeitet wurde was da noch
rechtlich belangt werden kann das ist
das eine das zweite ist aus dem vatikan
wurde angekündigt dass man sich
natürlich auch dieses gutachten genau
anschauen wird und dann wird sich die
frage stellen gibt es auch
kirchenrechtlich noch mal
dinge die aufzuarbeiten sind und urteile
die zu sprechen sind und das dritte ist
dann noch mal die frage nach der
moralischen verantwortung also der ein
oder andere fall der dann auch verjährt
ist wo sich natürlich die
verantwortlichen die jetzt ja klar
definiert sind bei den einzelnen
entfernen wo die sich soweit sie noch
leben stelle fragen müssen in welcher
weise habe ich eine moralische
verantwortung und muss aktiv werden muss
etwas tun sei es auf jeden fall erstmal
eine eine entschuldigung die überhaupt
erstmal auszusprechen jawohl ich habe
die fehler gemacht wenn man sich ein
bisschen anschaut die die stellungnahmen
die teilweise in dem gutachten anhängen
soweit ich sehe jetzt bei den 1700 1800
seiten in der kürze der zeit auch schon
mal über fliegen konnte da scheint mir
das nicht sehr ausgeprägt zu sein dieser
gedanke die verantwortung zu übernehmen
also auch dazu gucken
verantwortung übernehmen sich hinstellen
und dann schauen welche konsequenzen man
persönlich daraus ziehen kann wenn man
zum beispiel ein emeritierter erzbischof
ist sie haben es angesprochen das sind
über 1000 seiten also dieses gutachten
und es sind so viele punkte dabei ich
versuche sie irgendwie aufzudröseln also
vielleicht um das auch noch mal klar
nachzureichen also es sollen insgesamt
40 kleriker auch sein dass es auch
interessant die nach bekannt
bekanntwerden der missbrauchsfälle also
weiter in der seelsorge tätig waren bei
acht seien sogar nach einschlägiger
verurteilung heißt es in dem gutachten
wie kann sowas sein wie wurde dazu noch
ein bisschen mehr bekannt
also es ging heute morgen dann jetzt
erstmal noch nicht ins detail es ist
aber durchaus ein muster das man auch an
anderen stellen und in allen in
deutschland oder auch der weltkirche
sieht in einer zeit in der viele dinge
ja dann auch nicht öffentlich wurden
auch solche verurteilungen von tätern wo
dann diese wieder in der seelsorge
eingesetzt wurden gelegentlich gab es
dann auch gutachten also es gibt immer
wieder auch den fall dass dir zusammen
bischöfe psychiatrische gutachten haben
anfertigen lassen und da hieß es dann am
ende des gutachtens okay dieser mann ist
wieder einsetzbar ich habe mit
verschiedenen bischöfen auch gesprochen
die dann sagten ja in den 70er 80er
jahren darauf habe ich vertraut auf
dieses urteil habe ihn wieder eingesetzt
heute würde man so was wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr machen oder sehr sehr viel
vorsichtiger damit umgehend da glaube
ich schon oder bin mir sicher dass das
bewusstsein auch bei den
verantwortlichen in den bistümern
gewachsen ist aber wir reden hier über
über die 70er 80er jahre und damals wenn
ein gutachten vorlag das sagte sie
können den mann wieder einsetzen dann
gibt es viele bischöfe darauf vertraut
haben und heute müssen sie erkennen das
war ein fehler ich möchte ein paar
kommentare aufgreifen aus dem stream
hier gibt es mehrere meinungen dazu vor
allem was ich häufig lese ist austreten
schreiben hier manches seibert bei
youtube schreibt austreten leute
austreten meint also aus der
katholischen kirche austreten auch hier
noch ein weiterer kommentar von tz sich
nur die abkürzung das system kirche ist
überholt und undurchsichtig also viele
kritische stimmen die wir hier lesen das
ist natürlich jetzt auch eine frage also
was macht das insgesamt mit der
katholischen kirche da gab es auch eine
forsa umfrage die wir beide gelesen
hatten da hieß es nur noch zwölf prozent
der menschen die vertrauen überhaupt in
die katholische kirche also wie ist da
insgesamt ja wie sieht die zukunft jetzt
aus
also die kirche die katholische kirche
in deutschland ist spätestens seit 2010
der missbrauchsskandal ja in die
öffentlichkeit kam seitdem eigentlich
dauernd im krisenmodus die
kirchenaustrittszahlen sind enorm hoch
im vergangenen jahr noch mal gesteigert
an vielen stellen das liegen erste
zahlen vor zum beispiel für das
erzbistum köln da gab es ja auch viel
debatten um ein gutachten um die
veröffentlichung nicht veröffentlichung
und dann um den kardinal von köln
kardinal woelki da gab es höchst zahlen
bei den austritten das wird
wahrscheinlich an vielen anderen stellen
ähnlich sein
damit hat die katholische kirche zu
kämpfen sie haben es erwähnt der
immensen vertrauensverlust und
eigentlich das vertrauen die
glaubwürdigkeit das ist eigentlich die
währung für eine institution wie die
kirche und wenn die am boden liegt dann
ja dann muss ich muss man schon die
frage stellen ob die institution nicht
verloren ist es ist angeklungen durch
kardinal marx man versucht durch
reformen sozusagen einen turnaround zu
schaffen
zumindest eine basis auf der dann auch
wieder vertrauen wachsen kann
es gibt eine ganze reihe von bischöfen
die sagen uns ist es wirklich ernst mit
veränderungen und die müssen das jetzt
aber auch erst mal beweisen und zeigen
dieser reformprozess der angesprochen
wurde dieser sogenannte synodale weg das
ist ein prozess der jetzt gut bedingt
durch die pandemie auch nochmal
ursprünglich auf zwei jahre angelegt
jetzt sind wir schon bei drei jahren
vielen menschen reicht es nicht mehr die
sagen wir wollen jetzt veränderungen wir
haben schon seit jahrzehnten auf
veränderungen gewartet seit elf jahren
ist mittlerweile der missbrauchsskandal
offenkundig auch in deutschland das geht
uns alles zu langsam aber das ist der
einzige weg in die kirche hat
veränderungen reform transparenz und
verantwortung übernehmen und da wird
auch noch der ein oder andere rücktritt
kommen müssen weil die menschen sonst
den den kirchenverantwortlichen das
nicht abnehmen dass es ihnen wirklich
ernst wird wenn sie das immer wieder auf
irgendwelche ach ich hab mir war nicht
richtig ausgebildet die akten waren
nicht richtig geführt ich habe das nicht
gewusst haben jenes nicht gewusst
die menschen erwarten dass hier jemand
hinstellt und sagt ja wollten ich habe
fehler gemacht und deshalb muss ich
persönliche konsequenzen ziehen die
wahrscheinlich könnte den rücktritt von
kardinal marx sein was glauben sie er
hatte ja schon mal letzten sommer danach
gefragt bei papst franziskus aber das
fand nicht statt
also das ist im moment schwer
abzuschätzen dazu muss man jetzt mal
schauen wie wie er jetzt auch mit den
verantwortlichen im erzbistum münchen
und freising mit den ergebnissen des
gutachtens umgeht er hat er hat es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass er den den rücktritt
noch mal ein reich bei ihm kann man
schon feststellen dass ich würde mal
sagen vielleicht seit zwei jahren er
sich doch sehr stark verändert hat
nochmal und ihm doch die sag ich mal die
das schleppende vorankommen der
aufarbeitung jetzt wenn man es dann auch
noch einmal auf die gesamte weltkirche
sieht auch das schleppende vorankommen
mit veränderungen die für ihn ja wie wir
gehört haben ganz entscheidend sind um
den menschen zu zeigen haben es kapiert
nachdem das alles so langsam vorangeht
stelle ich fest in der beobachtung und
ich beobachtete dann klingt das ganze
geschäft ja schon seit über 25 jahren
aber jetzt bei ihm noch mal zu sehen
dass er sehr nachdenklich geworden ist
sein rücktrittsangebot war von daher für
mich durchaus auch nachvollziehbar weil
er irgendwie auch versucht hat glaube
ich mit diesem also mit dieser völlig
unerwarteten geschichte auch noch mal
irgendwie ein
[Musik]
exempel zu statuieren
etwas mit wumms sozusagen zu machen dass
alle anderen aufrüttelt oder dass viele
aufrüttelt das ist ein bisschen verpufft
dadurch dass der papst den rücktritt
nicht angenommen hat
also ich erwarte jetzt nicht in den
nächsten wochen noch mal eine
wiederholung des rücktritts angebot aber
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen je nachdem
wie sich die dinge jetzt in den nächsten
wochen und monaten auch entwickeln
nächste woche wird sich kardinal marx
dazu also ausführlich äußern für heute
abend erst mal vielen dank an jürgen
erbacher unseren kirchen experte für die
katholische kirche vielen dank und auch
vielen dank an euch für die fragen und
euer interesse wir hoffen wir konnten
einige davon bei diesem komplexen großen
thema beantworten und nächste woche
beschäftigt uns das wahrscheinlich dann
wieder also bis dahin vielen dank und
tschüss